it's hard to tell if I had writer's
block because it seems to me that it's
when nothing comes but you know every
day you stare at that computer screen
and I think it's never going to happen
today how can I write three pages and
the hours pass and they haven't shown up
and then at the very end it always
happens so it's it's the willpower you
just just to keep going and make pages
and then you can out of the pages you
produce you can take something because I
overwrite incredibly I write hundreds of
pages for this book is 198 pages but my
cuts file is 400 so a lot of that is me
not stopping you know what I mean so
that's I think I musta gotten through it
definitely I think it's max tivoli was
because he loved to write the devil you
know as as someone said about Milton you
know I he's a pretty unlikable character
but because he would talk these
Victorian flourishes and could be
incredibly overdone and garish but get
away with it somehow because it's of the
time setting I just enjoyed that freedom
you don't get to write like that ever no
writing program will let you get away
with that so it was it was great you
could be so cruel I cut out mushroom
cool stuff but I loved writing at me
well definitely for writing what
inspires me is poetry which I have next
to me all the time because I think
they're doing what I'm doing but much
harder more condensed it's the same job
but but much but they're more talented
all of them so I just steal openly from
them yeah I love it and also definitely
bewildering situations not just people
but traveling a lot I think that helps a
lot in the job that you because the lot
of the job is sitting in a room alone
and you can't do that you still write
about people because it helps the
writing yeah it does I can't you know
I'm lucky that I am NOT an attic but
when the end of the book comes and you
want it to work and you want the emotion
there there's nothing like sitting there
with a bottle of whiskey and I'm not
that kind of guy at all but but it works
you know and I think because it's it's a
tough thing it's hard to there's tougher
things in life than being a novelist but
you have such a struggle with yourself
that's hard to explain it seems like it
should just write itself easily but the
doubt is so intense that a drink now and
then can cure it and if you bent the
wrong way which it's also a crutch to
writers rely on things that work the
magic pen and paper and view and if you
know the whiskey works once you could
not want to miss
I have done it a little bit well in
story of a marriage there are a couple
all you would have to be a true crazy
dorky fan of max tivoli to see
everything that i carried over but it's
there was for my own fun that there's
some of the characters minor characters
from there you know and I considered
ride trying to write max tivoli again so
I'm kind of sequel but it's hard to
imagine how I could do it but maybe
someday or maybe one of the other
characters